ah there's the naked man welcome Hey
naked yeah pick out your clothes there's
nothing wrong with the default
outfit just you're just naked that's
fine you're just weird you're weird your
costumes are just weird we got dragon
ball costumes you guys just don't take
this job seriously of course we do
that's why we dressed for it you're the
one that shows up naked I showed up for
the job that I was hired for and
you I want the company the the company
the company we love the company hey hey
hey love the hey
he love the
company the company loves me
too ah they don't
actually so wait uh how we doing we're
going to go to a way too expensive place
it's way too dangerous and way above our
skill level and we're not going to be
able to survive or make any money and
then we're going to die is that what's
going to happen that is the plan all
right good that was a test Bob are you
going to get the newest piece of
technology then you can get your hands
on and then you're going to abuse it and
use it way too much and then blow it up
and then lose it for everybody H yeah
obviously okay cool just checking uh so
wait what's the deal I'm spending all my
money to be good at
bees to be good at
bees yeah we're good at bees what what
does that mean what does it mean we're
good at bees I don't know we're
beekeepers shovel and flashlights be on
the ground when we get down here let's
go let's go I can't pull the L let's go
I'm special I did it you might be
special but we are the
company is there any kind of uh Mission
prep any kind of information about this
that we can
do uh we're good at be now we're good at
be we got stuff over here to grab we're
good at bees
okay we love the company company and
company and we love the
come I I man I trailed off there and I
said we love the come but I meant more
like we love said we love the love yeah
the comp yeah but it sounded I I was
worried that you guys might have
misconstrued as being the comp can you
grab the put on the ship
the I love
the
okay man they really don't let me live
anything down I love the come on me
that's okay that now you're just saying
weird so honestly I I would make fun of
what you're saying cuz that's
ridiculous and they come on
[Applause]
[Music]
me these guys are so
immature already racking up the dollar
boys better get on my level and also I
want to reiterate like I was trying to S
we sing We love the company it's not
about come on
me the come on me the come on me come on
me okay you know the maturity levels are
really just very high and it's also okay
if that's your lifestyle I'm not judging
but I'm I'm saying it's not mine I'm
just trying to throw that out there it's
not
mine hey guys over
is it
yours uh no I can't hear that over the
radio whatever that was uh couldn't hear
it oh okay
[Music]
good H silence love the silence I'm
hearing which is nothing I'm sorry I was
bu being jump scared by bom
horiness
[Music]
come
oh
[Music]
what
uh you guys all right is there is there
luck
quiet we're good everything's fine
everything's fine don't
[Music]
worry okay all right well that's what I
get for caring so whatever jokes on you
if I die and what okay all right
oh
iway wait you did you go out the fire
door no I went the I went the direction
I told you I thought we had to
go M
hello hello
hello did I hear you guys were you
talking to me was someone talking to
me what oh where where are you are you
on the other side of a wall or something
you're like beneath me oh hi I'm I'm in
the generator
room I don't know where that
is you're really close to where I
am all
[Music]
call
oh my God oh God
what oh
okay
[Music]
oh my flashlight just burn out Mark how
did you get where you
are there's something stomping around
here there's something stomping around
don't trust my voice if you hear my
voice
what
okay I made it outside I don't know what
there's something very large and
stomping in that exact area that we were
I thought I heard it approaching me and
then it went
away Mark um there's a character Jus as
B who's running around
threateningly
uh yeah oh yeah you guys are both
outside I was about to run point on
you
yep did you hear a noise out here did
you see some lights no I didn't see
anything where's Bob am I hallucinating
oh there you are Bob you were invisible
for a little bit hey Bob you wait Bob
look at look at me look at me Bob look
at me Bob
[Music]
yeah what what the [__] you do ah
secrets secrets secrets
yeah go go go leave leave leave and
gone all
right oh oh Mark go go Mark
go go go
go I don't I don't know what that was
did you see did you see a Minecraft guy
here no no I didn't see anything oh I
don't know what I don't know what
happened did Wade die because he
deserved to I you know probably but it's
not good for us to speak ill of the
deserv Dead why did you get the only
notes the laziest employee the most
paranoid employee and God oh hey wait
how's it going do you guys have the
flashing lights in the horrible face no
no no I'm sure it's fine then thanks for
watching
stuff yeah okay yeah no yeah uhhuh all
right we're going to go to the map that
started it all it's going to be F clangy
dangy noises is that bad you guys hear
that ship just it's been through a lot
for the company clanging just CL
clonking around you know yeah what's
with the
notebook The Notebook it's a notebook I
collected it again that's mine I dibs on
that okay that's Mark's notebook got it
that's fair I guess he did collect
y you have your do you have your walkie
w i
do save that oh it is the map that
started it
all why are there no bees now that we're
professional beekeepers I don't know
what you're talking about the we kept
them all they're kept I'm going in the
side door all right you got this good
luck why do you say good
luck walkie on
Boy walk's On walkie what's the other
button to do the walkie besides P it out
every time uh X hold X
gotcha understood thank
you
oh
no
oh all right fire exit not doing too
good I got to jump here uh wish me luck
guys oh God oh God oh
God made
it oh my
God
guys Mark I keep hearing you talk twice
at a time oh oh what the
freak okay so you hear me talk like
right now or later I hear you talking
but it's not you yeah well I wouldn't I
wouldn't immediately not trust that
sounds pretty
trustworthy
[Music]
hold that oh
God
okay I'm full up I'm going to go drop
some stuff off if you guys are still
alive wait now I literally can't haven't
found a damn
thing uh fire exit has some stuff you
got to make a jump but it has some
things okay headed back in I got a good
feeling about this where where the [__]
are oh hello how did you get over there
I stepped on a teleporter oh wait what
hey what's up hey what's going on
here uh I'm locked out more like you're
locked in come on me come on me okay I
hey love come on me that's kind of
disgraceful to the windy path I'm going
to follow it all right you do that
listen we need to have a word about this
come on me thing h
was there just a sound of a can
opening can opening crisp refreshing
Diet Coke yeah that was that's what I
did oh
god oh how did you get over there [__]
I'm
so
no oh we died right before my
[Music]
eyes well I'm going to try this oh the
come on me that's that's that that is
what he loved he did love that he loved
the come on me all right let's go grab
some stuff and get out of here I got to
kill hoing bug if you wanted to help me
do
that uh I don't have a shovel but you
have I got one I got one I got one you
just play decoy okay I saw one down here
this uh this I'm going to go for this
all right you do that I hear you where
you at where you at where you at get
it all right where'd it go come here hey
loot
give me the
loot oh that was
just oh my
God God oh my God entr
what what run you
idiot you fool flee flee
flee the loot bug
flee hey wait the loot bug what you what
do you mean there's a
spider it
left did
it it doesn't sound like it
left
left did
it
probably man I
have
what is
that what was that I'm leaving you what
was it I'm gone I might need a hand nope
nuh nope sorry I don't know what that
was Toy Soldier [__] is not part of
my contract I am out my friend I wish
you the best of luck run
fast
Mark which one of these which one of
these exits was real uh not that one it
was one at the end of a long hallway if
you want that
help no no did I think you were at
it yeah that
wait this
one
yeah he there you are I found this one
nice
item okay good that's great we're
getting out of here man I'm still
traumatized by Bob falling to his death
like that that
was right in front of our eyes right in
front of our eyes yeah I'm also
traumatized by being nearly killed by a
spider and having a nutcracker on my
face yeah I did tell you about that that
there was SP yeah The Nutcracker not so
much well I didn't know but I don't know
what that was but I think I had the
right instinct run away
hey oh hey guys how's it going hey hey
man I had the weirdest nightmare that
you fell to your
death no way that happened yeah no way
I'm so bad at this video game that
that's what happened uh-huh yeah and
that wouldn't happened to me for sure
was there a nutcracker in there um might
have been looked like it was right in
front of my face it looked like one what
was that is that allowed I thought they
were only in the other the house one
when the [__] that's called that's a
great question but it seemed to be there
right in front of me trying to trap me
in a corner didn't it yeah I know it it
seemed to be it seemed to be right there
did it have a gun at least nobody none
of us randomly exploded in front of each
other that time there was just a bad
fall in our Dream yeah know the The
Nutcrackers have shotguns oh shotguns oh
excellent should we shall we should we
shall we shall we shall I think I'm
bringing a shovel this time all right
I've kept from the entire time my lesson
no shovel for me all right sounds good
it's way you down on those
jumps oh he's who he's long gone holy
[__] oh you're both are long gone I'm
the one behind I'm the
fool where are we wait where are we
huhh what is this where are we uhoh
whooh oh where
what wait where where are we where am I
what
what did these guys forget that they
play this a lot more than me and they
just left me behind and I don't know
where we
are
what
[Music]
what I feel like you guys forgot that
I've I've never been here uh because you
play way more than me and I I didn't
know where the main entrance was I
definitely played way more than
you hello you found it yeah I found it
did you a tur there's a turret over
there there's a
turret oh
freck uh you don't want to go that other
way there's many
turrets oh okay I'm going turrets you
don't all right it's a
lot you don't know I saw I got an idea
yeah I'm not going to take of the
turrets all right sounds good I'll leave
this shovel here in case you guys need
it can you shovel a turret going for
it I'm the
[Music]
best oh my
God I hate that
sound I'm the best oh goo
goo
goo goo goo goo Bob goo I'm distracting
it I'll save you Bob oh look at me look
at me I'm so tasty you goo all the goo
come here you come here
goo Mark I saved your
life I I saw that the hell is happening
what the some of turrets have been dealt
with oh yeah they blew up oh all right
well thank you I guess yeah yeah man
yeah know that goo was about to goo you
up call if you see St all right appr
that all
right did you see how I said
Bob oh Jesus Christ I'm quick on the
draw this all looks like a dead end over
here um Bob go straight there I think
straight there's the way to go then
right or
left
dibs
Jesus God oh my
God oh thank thank you guess oh there's
a flask Oh weird okay he's
just happy
expion wish you could get like scrap
from them or
something all right o there's a present
should I open
it I'm going to open it oh that's nice
also the power seems to be off in there
I can't control doors at all so I can't
help you guys with
doors that's door nothing behind
it to go straight and then turn
right
be yeah there I saw something what what
did I what did what did I just see what
did what did I just there was a slug
there was a slug there was a slug
there's an item to your left oh oh no
wait straight you're good there's it
straight ahead and there's another item
across from that uh did you see the wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute we got a problem wait
you're not in here are you no I
not
oh oh my God oh my God oh God care oh oh
God is this a real fire exit is it real
is real tell me it's real Mark are you
okay some amount of turrets have been
dealt with oh my God oh my God is this
fire exit real is it real oh my
God uh mark this is a dead end room oh
it's the back rooms uh Wade you are
currently following
me oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh oh my God oh my God oh
my God oh my God oh my God that the only
door in out
oh yep I got a rodeo Rambo oh my god oh
oh God right on you that is the real
fire that is a real fire real real real
room oh I'm made it uh Bob looks like
there's a slime creeping up on you so be
careful copy that thank
you oh I'm kind of a dead end here
whoopsie Mark there's a big giant red
dot uh going after you
uh I'm outside Mark are you all
right it's horrible it's terrible what
he's saying is he made to the night
Beyond imagination I thought that thing
was just going to Camp the door and not
let you leave I don't know I didn't even
see it I didn't even know what it was
but you you terrifying [__] when
you were in there oh God what oh
God oh God B run run run Bob run Bob run
run oh my
God he died right before our
eyes
again oh my God oh my God what the oh my
God I started the ship oh it's coming
with us oh my
God it's just his feet were just there I
just yeah I just saw that big freaking
leg it's mey thigh just
flapped Jesus what the [__] hi hi hey
man did you
um did you how I died no there was a
swirl of like bugs or something or birds
and then a giant red dot was Over You
Ah that's kind of unfortunate did you
see how you died no I really couldn't I
just kind of died yeah and there was a
giant red circle on the map we heard
like and then you were gone yeah yeah we
were trying to say run cuz it was
literally coming up right behind you and
I heard you I heard you say run once and
then I just was not anymore ah so do we
have to go to the company right now yeah
yeah it's company time oh okay listen
you can't say anything about come
there
okay oh that chair is going yeah the
chair and Freddy are both
possessed that's
okay
hello hello at least there's no
nightmares
here
why's Freddy yeah there there aren't
creatures here are there oh Jesus it
opened what yeah it opened it does that
yeah I just scared me I I just turned my
back real quick there's a couple more
small items here yep I think we're good
on the
qua yeah we got
it anything else I don't think so all
right we're definitely going to make
quota I bought some stuff
oh more items over here if you got room
uh I'm starting to think maybe I should
bring more shovels with me well I
haven't used the shovel yet so I don't
know if it's done me any good I'm going
sell this thing I love to come on me
look come on me all right all right now
come on me all right so we did really
good there that was great I think it was
we're going back up okay how do you um
how do you get can you get a gun is
there guns um me you can try to fight
one of The Nutcrackers for one there's a
stun
gun can you buy uh oh also is it no can
you tell us how to blow up a turret just
in case we need to do that yeah so you
come to this computer you type view
space monitor when we're on a moon it
won't work if we're in space on moon
it's view space monitor it'll show you
the map then turrets doors and mines
will have a letter number designation
like v0 H5 so on and so forth type that
in and they will explode however if
anyone's close to it when you detonate
they will die right okay that's that's
that's the Crux of it but view space
monitor switch switches who you're
looking at and then the letter number
for whatever you want to either open or
blow up you get a rocket launcher what
oh flare guns on sale there's a rocket
launcher oh dude there's a rocket
launcher the paid moons we we only have
enough to we can't afford a paid well we
can afford dime free thing in a rocket
launcher or do you want to go to a paid
Moon upk free thing and a rocket
launcher those paid moons with the
bridge is off to the right okay good
okay um do you want to buy the rocket
launcher yes
yeah I don't know if I want to be in
charge of it by loud horn ship upgrades
what what does that even mean what is a
signal translator what's a loud horn oh
loud Horn's pretty good no rocket
launcher but it's pretty I'm going to
land us uh okay this is not what I was
expecting you to buy all right loud horn
where is
it
oh well we got to rotate that and then a
little should I land us way oh yeah go
for it I mean go ahead but brace
yourself but also hold on but also hold
on oh give for that God damn it and I
was trying to trying to adjust that but
I guess we're I can't now all right all
right all right all right walkie on
Fellers I want to I want to be I want to
be Boatman be why is way
[Music]
dead